bonsoir bienvenue en basse normandie au
village des jeux équestres mondiaux parc
des expositions de caen deuxième jour de
compétition et regarder tout de suite
ces images du premier podium de ses 7e
jeux équestres le podium du dressage par
équipes bonsoir florent turpin ces
soirées bien au dressage la discipline à
la base de toutes les disciplines
équestres c'est comme en football
à la fin c'est l'allemagne qui gagne oui
les allemands et les britanniques grand
favori de ces jeux équestres mondiaux
qui brille déjà dans la compétition une
deuxième journée avec une météo et oui
assez clémente il a même parfois fait
beau sur les sites de compétition
presque pas de pluie mais plein de
belles images et midi et milieu ouvert à
ça tout à l'heure on va revenir dans un
instant mais d'abord un coup d'oeil sur
le reste de l'actualité c'est d'abord la
composition du nouveau gouvernement de
manuel valls et bien bernard cazeneuve
l'ancien maire de charlesbourg à reste
au ministère de l'intérieur
autre information importante que la
réouverture du pont mathilde à rouen
pour le plus grand soulagement des
automobilistes qui peuvent l'emprunter
depuis 17 heures cet après midi il avait
fermé en octobre 2012 après un très
important incendie
il avait donc été fermé pendant 22 mois
aller retour à caen aux jeux équestres
mondiaux florent que s'est il passé en
dressage on a vu le sacre de l'allemagne
par équipes mais quand on regarde les
performances des français on est un peu
déçu journée mitigée pour l'équipe de
france de dressage au stade d'ornano
mais c'est pourtant une cavalière au nom
très français qui a brillé aujourd'hui
vous la voyez elle s'appelle charlotte
du jardin à la 29 ans elle est jolie et
c'est la grande star mondiale de la
discipline sans surprise la cavalière
britannique a pris cet après-midi la
tête du classement provisoire sursaut
valve allegro le joli passage également
cet après-midi du français arnaud serre
que l'on va voir ici à l'image le
français sous l'ovation des 8000
spectateurs du stade d'ornano s'est
classé 20e
en revanche et jessica michel l'autre
grand espoir de l'équipe de france s'est
quant à elle totalement manqué elle
n'est pas qualifiée pour le grand prix
spécial qui va réunir les 30 meilleurs
cavaliers de ce premier tour je vous
propose de l'écouter jessica michel au
micro de corinne vie en rose à jessica
michel une note autour de 68 comment
vous avez senti votre humeur alors elle
était vraiment génial et j'ai adoré
monter dans cette arène avec tant de
public français être acclamé comme ça à
l'entré champ cela n'arrive qu'en france
ou alors si on est dans les trois
meilleurs mondiaux et c'était vraiment
génial j'ai vraiment tout donné elle a
tout donné aussi malheureusement on
n'est pas parfait et ça on sait et
je suis très très très contente de leur
crise alors il ya deux ans jeune on vous
étiez là la seule française aujourd'hui
il ya une véritable équipe de dressage
en france ça change vraiment les choses
à bas la pression est répartie sur
quatre cavaliers au lieu que ce soit sur
un cavalier alors forcément c'est mieux
on peut se suivre venir se voit on est
plusieurs à avoir la même épreuve et ça
c'est très sympa oui andré jacques
goupil vous êtes notre consultant pense
que si le speaker de cso la semaine
prochaine est ce qu'on peut parler de
contre performance pour jessica michel
par rapport à ce qu'on aurait souhaité
rêvait peut-être un petit peu trop rêver
peut-être mais si on regarde tous ces
résultats en grand prix depuis depuis
deux ans hormis les jeux de londres où
elle sort à 70% et encore aller 31e donc
n'avait pas repris dans le grand prix
spécial
elle est toujours à 40,60 on voit son
cheval là là on est on est sûr c'est sur
ces points faibles il commence elle
commence une reprise magnifique elle est
montée jusqu'à 75% et quand ses points
faibles sont arrivés la transition
passagers le piaf et dans au moins assez
jolie pirouette voilà ça c'est le
passage pas le sait pas s'en passer ses
allures préférées et ça c'est pas bien
passé aujourd'hui donc on les reverra
plus jessica michel qui monte une jument
allemande une oldenburg rivera de us et
il faut savoir qu'on dressage et bien
deux écoles s'affrontent depuis toujours
l'école allemande hollandaise et l'école
ibérique et les choses sont en train de
changer corridors et oui petit à petit
donc 2 école de dressage est depuis
longtemps une suprématie presque totale
des races hollandaise et allemande
vous allez voir sur ces images un cheval
hollandais ce sont de grands chevaux
assez aérien souvent avec des robes font
ces défauts qui ont beaucoup d'amplitude
dans les mouvements qui monte très haut
leur dos vous le voyez encore là sur
cette entrée sur la carrière et puis
donc en face et bien les chevaux
ibériques portugais ou espagnols comme
ceux que l'on retrouve dans les corridas
plus petit avec une encolure plus large
et qui montrent les jeunes ou beaucoup
plus haut vous voyez dans cette allure
qu'on appelle le passage mais qui ont
moins d'amplitude dans leurs mouvements
vous allez encore le voir là sur ces
changements de pied donc ces chevaux
ibériques sont moins bien notés par les
juges mais ils sont en train de
rattraper leur retard et on a vu ici une
très très bonne équipe espagnole donc
petite toute petite révolution dans le
milieu très fermé du dressage milieu
très fermé merci corinne florence et est
aujourd'hui également la deuxième
journée du para dressage mais c'était à
l'hippodrome de caen on va le voir
devant des tribunes encore bien vide ce
matin il faut le dire en par adressage
les cavaliers on le sait sont handicapés
ils sont répartis en grade selon
l'importance de leur handicap
ce matin place aux cavaliers de grade 4
1 vous voyez ici à l'image
la cavalière française nathalie et bizet
qui après un très bon passage s'est
emparé de la sixième place du classement
provisoire est avec nous sur ce plateau
valérie salesse bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes cavalière de
parra dressage grade 1 baissait de vous
est paraplégique
on vous a vu concourir hier alors que
cette mode par équipes
vous l'avez fait pour tester la piste
c'est ce que font la plupart des
cavaliers c'est ce que font la plupart
des cavaliers aujourd'hui nous sommes
tous partants sur la première épreuve
qu'elle soit par team test ou part
individuelle pour notre propre
participation alors c'était seulement
sept mois que vous avez votre jus mon
diamond eu loin d'une princesse ou i7
mois c'est peu c'est très peu c'est très
court
malheureusement il nous faudrait
quelques mois de plus pour se dire qu'on
est au top
mais voilà je suis au top et je suis là
donc quoi dire de plus c'est vraiment
galéré ne pas le dire autrement on
pourra voir un cheval et c'est souvent
le cas on parlera dressage j'ai beaucoup
galéré c'est souvent le cas puisque
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a quand même
beaucoup de cavaliers dont thibault
stoclin dont la dîmière vin chaud - même
qui l'a télévisé qui a vendu des
nouveaux chevaux tout juste cette année
donc on galère parce que c'est dur de
convaincre les propriétaires
c'est dur de d'en trouver c'est dur de
les convaincre de nous confier de nous
louer des chevaux afin de pouvoir faire
du para dressage et à haut niveau tous
dans le même temps heureusement il ya
maintenant une structure qui est
l'institut français du cheval ifce qui
apporte son soutien avec également une
logistique
on est encore très en retard sur les
autres fédérations les britanniques bien
évidemment sont largement en avance ou
des chevaux qui ont couru en grand prix
comme ce qu'on vient de voir avec avec
jessica tout à l'heure ensuite parce et
deviennent des viandes les jambes par
exemple de cavaliers paraplégique comme
valérie mais on a encore beaucoup de
retard
oui mobilisation sur facebook et avec
nos confrères d'equidia qu'on salue au
passage je vous dis dimon du loing votre
parcours vous êtes une ancienne
cavalière d'obstacles je craque et de
plats oui vous avez fait une chute qui
vous a handicapé et six mois après vous
être monté à cheval
c'est le cas de la plupart des claviers
par dressage il ne rejette pas le cheval
pour autant non je pense que la mort du
cheval quand elle est là on la tient
quoi ça reste dans nos coeurs et ça
reste ma passion je pense à vie quoi
qu'il arrive c'est vrai que la plupart
de nous dans la compétition et dans
l'équipe de france on est tous revenu
sur sur le cheval et ça nous apporte
énormément donc bien sûr on est tous là
merci beaucoup à l'original on pensera à
vous demain matin on croise les doigts
on suivra ça florent on regarde
maintenant ce qu'a donné ce deuxième
jour de compétition cette fois ci en
reining oui les épreuves de reining qui
se déroule au parc des expositions
ambiance rodéo et western et commis hier
d
figure assez impressionnante grosse
déception en revanche pour le français
franck perrais numéro un mondial victime
on va dire ça comme ça d'une ruade de
son cheval sur un changement de
direction
on va l'avoir encore mieux sur cette
image ça n'a l'air de rien mais ça lui a
coûté très cher au classement puisqu'il
n'est que 75e en revanche belle
satisfaction pour un petit bas-normands
le voilà ce matin il s'appelle bastien
bourgeois il habite à bellengreville
dans le calvados il termine dans les 40
premiers c'est vraiment pas mal écouté
le c'était aux micros de france béni ici
voilà on est en france
les trois quarts des gradins sont
remplies par des français effectivement
ils attendent donc voila voila comme
j'ai dit je suis un peu déçu du score où
ça va pas forcément
et est ce que j'attendais j'attendais un
petit peu plus voilà les jugeons pas
crédité c'est voilà c'est dit et c'est
du haut niveau là c'est dur d'aller
chercher des points
andré-jacques le coup de cul la ruade du
cheval de franck perrais
c'est surprenant on vois plutôt ça en
saut d'obstacles mois en reining en soit
ça soit une ruade de joie ou de denain
discipline je crois je regardais encore
une fois c'est vrai qu'il sa transition
pour ralentir parce que là ils vont très
très vite dans cercle puis il faut
repasser gallo travail me semble-t-il
c'est vrai qu'il l'a fait un petit peu
peur je juge pas est ce que c'est ça
qu'il n'a pas aimé
ou alors est-ce que ça peut être une
juste une douleur sur le dos le cheval
glisse un petit peu par un parent
sliding comme ça c'est peut-être une
douleur l édile rudy hop ça m'a fait mal
mais par contre c'est sanctionner par
les juges immédiatement dommage pour
frank perry allez on sort des résultats
un moment pour s'intéresser au bien-être
de ces sportifs de très haut niveau que
sont les chevaux que l'on peut voir ici
ou josé casse mondiaux 170 vétérinaires
sont mobilisés pendant ces jeux et sur
tous les sites des cliniques et des
laboratoires ont été installés en
reportage dans l'orne au haras du pin
qui accueillera à partir de jeudi le
concours complet à dell de celle ci
patrick mars à granville au bord de la
mer en galopant sur la plage et avec le
sable et les guette faculty cavitation
sur la peau à quelques jours du concours
complet la moindre blessure est prise
très au sérieux par le vétérinaire de
l'équipe une infection locale
j'ai un petit peu leur médecin de
famille je les connais très bien je les
ai suivis tout au long de la saison je
les ai vus en compétition j'ai participé
au stage de préparation à la sélection
en tout 35 vétérinaires seront sur le
site au moment des épreuves une clinique
a été installé pour gérer les chevaux
malades ou blessés on a cinq boxes qu'on
appelle des boks fatma qui permettent
aux vétérinaires des équipes de traiter
leurs chevaux on a toute une série de
bureaux pour les vétérinaires on à la
pharmacie on peut tous traités on va
dire les premières urgences
et puis dès que ça va devenir un petit
peu compliqué nécessitant beaucoup de
médicaments ou en tout cas des moyens
peut-être un peu plus important que ce
qu'on a ici c'est évacuer référés vers
des cliniques à l'extérieur pour que
rien ne vienne perturber les jeux
équestres les vétérinaires suivent la
santé des chevaux de très près dès leur
arrivée
un premier examen est réalisée pour
évaluer l'état général de l'animal
fréquence cardiaque vaccination
températures tout est vérifié comme pour
les athlètes de haut niveau
les diagnostics doivent pouvoir être
fait au plus vite sur le site un
laboratoire est opérationnel 24 heures
sur 24 on va frotter un peu la muqueuse
nasale du chef jack holt et quelques
quelques cellules et les éventuels les
éventuels agents pathogènes qui pourrait
que le cheval pourraient avoir
l'objectif détecter les animaux malades
pour éviter toute contamination
au total 170 vétérinaires sont mobilisés
pour ces jeux équestres sur les
différents sites
andré jacques pourquoi autant de soin
finalement n'apporte plus de soin aux
chocs aux cavaliers je crois qu alors
déjà il faut saluer le nombre incroyable
de vétérinaires bénévoles qui sont
coupés pour fabriquer un vrai commando
bourse pour soigner les chevaux veiller
sur les chevaux il ya des chevaux qui
vient du monde entier qui voyage vous
savez que les virus ça peut voyager
aussi donc ils sont là pour éviter que
ça se propage pour leur sécurité
et puis après il ya le vétérinaire qui
vont s'occuper vraiment des athlètes
donc veiller à ce que tout aille bien
jusqu'à la fin de la compétition
il ya aussi des vétérinaires qui sont là
pour les contrôles antidopage donc ils
sont effectivement surveiller au
millimètre du jour et mettre le pied sur
le site jusqu'au jour ils repartent le
cheval n'est pas un animal
particulièrement fragile mais c'est un
vous voyez enfin je pense qu'il va vous
émerveiller encore pendant pendant ces
deux semaines c'est un athlète de très
très haut niveau et il parle pas donc il
faut essayer de voir à sa place ce qui
va ou ce qui va pas on prend la
température du cheval pour savoir si un
petit problème ou pas alors on va
maintenant retrouver hélène jacques dans
le village des jeux avec le syndicat
national des éleveurs de cob normand
l'autre cheval de trait de chez nous
moins connu que le percheron mais qui
gagne est reconnue ln oui bonsoir emilie
bonsoir à tous je suis avec norbert
coulon un des ambassadeurs du cob
normand le coq qui est à l'honneur
pendant ces jeunes alors il vient vous
dire pourquoi il faut promouvoir cette
phrase brewer parce que la plaine
qualité et que c'est une race classe est
menacée
on peut l'utiliser à des fins montée ou
bien être les comme aujourd'hui c'est
une race très légère kaeppelin
d'aptitude en plein d'avenir j'espère et
pourtant pourtant il ya un manque de
naissance un gain psy oui oui
depuis quelques années on s'aperçoit que
le nombre de naissances a sérieusement
de luminy on est passé de 600 à 200 en
l'espace de cinq ans
la majorité des éleveurs sont très âgés
donc les jumeaux et disparaissent avec
la avec les éleveurs il ya très peu de
jeunes qui reprennent l'activité quoi
alors on se dit là vous êtes vous
champion de france d'attelage de cob
normand vous étiez deuxième à coupe du
monde pourquoi on les retrouve pas où je
séquestre mondiaux mais ce serait
peut-être un rêve mais ils font pas
partie de la même famille il a là on est
dans la famille des forêts et le faux
200 sont des aptitudes différentes
peut-être un peu plus rapide avec plus
semble justement mais pourra faire des
jeux mondiaux des shows très bon alors
y'a initiatives intéressantes pendant
ces jeux équestres ici au village vous
parrainez un poulain étoiles finances
oui étoiles ça allait donner l'occasion
aux gens qu'on le pas les moyens d'avoir
un cheval de suivre en direct
l'évolution et le développement de la
pouliche sur internet sur le site du
syndicat et les gens peuvent donner ce
qu'ils veulent et puis se rendre au
stand 1 du code normand sur l'espace
normand pour en avoir un peu plus de
renseignements tous les jours il ya des
balades voilà d'attelage on peut vous
retrouver ici dans le village merci à
vous ok merci à vous merci à tous les
deux il y avait un peu plus de monde
aujourd'hui un dans le village des jeux
puisqu'il n'a pas plu plus de monde
également dans les tribunes plus de
spectateurs sur les lieux de compétition
et beaucoup de familles car l'équitation
est un sport hautement transmissible
voyez le reportage de stéphanie lemaire
et de cyril duponchel d'el feel zoé et
lola devrait être bien placé pour
admirer le dressage
elles sont venues de rambouillet pour
partager ce moment
pourquoi venir en famille parce que
c'est rarissime c'est tous les quatre
ans les jeux c'est en france donc je
pense qu'il faut aussi encourager la
discipline et puis leur montrait un beau
spectacle dans le stade d'ornano la
compétition a déjà commencé sous le
regard attentif de spectateurs de tous
horizons
être ici en normandie et vivre
l'évènement à 4 prend sens pour cette
famille de souvenirs et presque sans
attirer chevaux d'ici et on les voit les
trails n'est pas du tout la même chose
que de voir à la télé watch
c'est génial quelques mètres plus loin
on retrouve delphine cette pièce fait
mais pour les charnières emploi depuis
qu'il a du mal à entrer dans piques
vous savez reçurent vraiment la
difficulté technique aussi de nom je
parle ça reste un chevalement ses plans
mobile est donc on
bon ben voilà il ya des choux
sont impressionnés
sentir maman
n'est ce pas j'ai fait c'est super
élégant
quant aux images peut-être que je vous
envie
amusant pelouse sommet
regardons si chance à 6 fin juin si
certains sont plus dissipés d'autres
petits ont bien conscience de la
difficulté du dressage
je pense que si un gosse je vais y
arriver un ce serait
moi
toute ma vie à la sortie du stade la
discipline n'a peut être pas conquis
tout le public est ce que tu aimerais
faire comme les cavaliers non
mais ce n'est peut-être qu'une question
d'âge les jeux sont des nuls
parmi les plus jeunes emmanuel chauny 1
vous a reconnu encore comment faisait on
peut recommencer avec le pioneer il faut
toute l'enfance d'andré-jacques le
groupe voilà c'est plus important que le
poney franchement avec un tout petit
poney 1 falbala 86 centimes et balleure
je sais pas mais moi je n'arriverai
jamais à prononcer par l'ebu rida de
petit-bourg ida j'arrive pas bien le
dire ces images vous de petit-bourg ida
voilà qu'on appelle communément la
fantasia mme sellah petits bouts reid
est ainsi mike est vous voulez mais des
gendres et j'ai accepté le sport et ce
traditionnel marocain en démonstration
c'est en milieu de journée dans le
village des jeux
l'occasion aussi de mettre à l'honneur
le barde marocain petit cheval très
endurant comment on dit andrée jelk la
tbourida poulies et le t on le comme un
peu comme à la corse mais dans l'autre
sens c'est une vraie discipline sportive
reconnue à la fédération royale
marocaine des sports équestres avec des
dizaines et des dizaines d' équipes en
compétition à la grande semaine du
cheval il faut qu'ils doublent tous très
très aligner les costumes là toute la
chorégraphie le moment où ils tirent
tous ensemble qui est assez
impressionnant faut que ce soit vraiment
tous ensemble la façon dont ils vont
s'arrêter au galop maintenant je sais
c'est vraiment ça partait de jeu de
village en fait toute une tradition et
c'est devenu au maroc une discipline
sportive
voilà donc pourquoi pas aux jeux
mondiaux un jour peut-être en 2072
florent qu'est ce qui nous attend demain
et rendez vous demain d2 dès 9 heures au
stade michel d'ornano pour le grand prix
spécial de dressage qui va réunir donc
les 30 meilleurs cavaliers à l'issue du
premier tour et puis toujours à 9 heures
début de la troisième journée de
compétition de parra dressage à
l'hippodrome de caen valérie on vous
retrouve demain matin demain matin après
midi là après midi en sera ce un petit
peu plus tard après tirage au sort voilà
au sec qu'on espère parce que j'espère
toucher belle douche est effectivement
on donnera le résultat demain soir de
valérie saleh ce jeudi se savent à
l'épreuve d'endurance dans la baie du
mont-saint-michel 160 km en plusieurs
boucles autour de sarti 170 chevaux et
cavaliers vont y participer ce devrait
être beau spectacle plus de 5000
spectateurs sont attendus
alors si vous voulez y aller que faut-il
savoir éléments de réponse avec
stéphanie vino et joël hama
l'endurance c'est un circuit de 160
kilomètres répartis en cinq parcours
pour les gens qui ont acheté un billet
il est conseillé d'arriver sur le site
de sortie dès 6 heures du matin pour
assister au départ vers 7 heures sans
billets il suffit de se positionner sur
le bord de la route
cet endroit avec des parkings ont été
tout spécialement préparé pour
accueillir le public
on a imaginé tous les dispositifs pour
les spectateurs qui peuvent se rendre
sur les plages de jullouville de kairon
de carole de dragey afin d'aller voir la
course à des heures bien précises
puisque les heures de passage ont été
communiqués et pour avoir les détails
des boucles et des horaires de passage
il suffit de se rendre sur le site
internet des jeux équestres mondiaux en
voiture le circuit est libre d'accès la
seule contrainte de circulation ce jour
là sera l'acte granville avranches qui
sera coupé de 7h à 10h au niveau de
saint pierre langers la première boucle
emprunté par les concurrents sectionne
rd 973 au niveau de la commune de saint
pierre langers donc là on est obligé de
n'interrompe totalement la circulation
dans les deux sens pendant le passage
des chevaux qui s'effectue en deux
phases une phase again phase retour il
est donc conseillé aux automobilistes
qui ferait avranches granville ou
inversement de passer par la haye pesnel
pour éviter le secteur et vous pouvez
retrouver toutes ces informations sur
notre site internet et notamment le plan
d'accès 1 pour aller a sorti voir cette
épreuve d'endurance sur notre site basse
tirer normandie point france 3 point fr
notre chronique quotidienne les pieds
dans le crottin ou les jeux équestres
mondiaux par le petit bout de la
lorgnette ce soir vous allez le voir
mathieu bellingen ne recule devant aucun
sacrifice alors impossible d'y échapper
la ville de caen affiches partout les
jeux équestres alors village des jeux 10
min à pied
on va tester pour vous est ce qu'il ya
vraiment
dimi c'est parti alors on y va
premier souci bas il ya un peu du monde
partout
je marche d'une bonne allure on va dire
la balade du mal croise des gens pour
qu'ils jouent et lisa cinq minutes 50
secondes et j'aperçois le village
6030 j'en profite pour faire un set
commence à devenir chauve la fin du
parcours en 30 minutes 10 secondes
maintenant tout à l'heure on a vu un
panneau qui indiquait village à 5
minutes ce n'était pas nouveau tome i
need a une limite voire à 30 secondes
c'est sabrina qui trichent là qui
prennent un peu loose allez je vais le
faire aussi tant pis nos deux buts
jusque là normalement et voilà douze
minutes 18 secondes et sept centièmes
c'est le temps exact pour refaire ses
dix minutes à pied ce pas trop mal
d'ailleurs un temps de parcours
mathieu bling et non en testeurs de des
parcours village des jeux emmanuel
chaunu wimille y donc ça y est 1 le
nouveau gouvernement valse 2 est
constituée alors regardez notre dresseur
en chef vient de ben voilà il a
rassemblé son écurie bon ya pas trop de
changements il n'y a pas une seule
oreille qui bouge et il va quand même
réussi une chose incroyable c'est qu'il
va aussi réussir à faire plier le
président républicain je pense parce que
c'est un excellent dresseur cci lancy
quelle race de cheval vous avez ses
parois la balle là où parfois ni à poney
1 kwh
non c'est pas comme de recul comme de
tulle voilà emmanuel regard des saisies
c'est fou ces images saisies into
étonnante de l'hippodrome de la prairie
à la fin du dix neuvième siècle
alors elle date de 1860 ces images mais
sachez qu'il ya exactement cent soixante
dix sept ans avait lieu la première
course sur l'hippodrome de la prairie le
26 août
1837 voila voila vous retrouvez
l'essentiel de ce qu'il faut savoir
cette deuxième journée des jeux et cas
sur notre site internet dans le soir 3
et autour de 23 heures demain à midi
gros plan sur l'endurance et on en
reparle demain soir bonne chose valérie
seles merci et à demain les gars
vous
à